boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on we
are select Co fest the Congress on the
future of engineering software for our
second annual partnership with them we
are now with mark 4 Waller hello and
thanks for coming out of the show really
appreciate it yeah it was so cool mark
and I were just at dinner together at
the wood dinner and of course as you
guys know I asked a question to the
table and I asked what do you guys think
is the weirdest thing in the world
and then Mark was the first one that was
like what was your exact answer it was
like something about conscious
experience something like that I think
it was you making some comment about
what if you are just and nothing and so
life wouldn't that be weird and that
generated the discussion of
consciousness yeah there was a there was
a good there was a good conversation on
at the table about about consciousness
and about really broad imagination and
what it would be like to even not have a
universe and be thinking from outside
the universe it was very interesting and
then we proceeded to continue talking
about philosophy and the meaning of life
mark actually went back across the table
and asked me what the meaning of life
was and then I just said it's
complicated
question and answer and then you said
that it was to live and then then there
was another comment that it's about
procreating and then there were just
really good conversation ensued because
we decided to shatter the small talk at
the table and dive into deeper
conversations about life so then of
course then I wanted to ask mark to come
on to the show to teach us about his
life and why he even thinks about
reality in the way he does and you had
some interesting stories of you know of
your son as well and the way that you've
traveled with your son and the reasons
why that that you gained a broader
perspective about culture and about
humanity
due to that but tell us about who you
are and about you know why you became
who you are today that's a great
question I wish I knew who I was I think
I have an idea but that's an idea so but
I I think you're asking about the
external exterior aspects of Who I am
one of your questions was how did I get
into engineering software's and maybe we
start there through that yeah um I went
to school you know when I graduated high
school and no I didn't want to be a
lawyer thought about being a doctor one
end engineering because at that time
that was considered next to those a good
profession and well sure what I wanted
to do but my dad said something when I
was a teenager that really impacted me I
felt like he wasn't completely happy at
his job but he he made a comment that
one of his superiors at one time said
that he would rather be pushing a
vegetable cart and working for himself
and to be working for the quote/unquote
man so sorry I had a desire for
self-employment you know when I was in a
got a master's degree in mechanical
engineering went to University of
Florida to get a PhD was in the robotics
department did about three semesters
there my son was born and I was kind of
became a little bit jaded towards the
whole PhD sort of idea
it just didn't hold the luster for me
that it had whenever I envisioned the
glory of it as a 12 or 13 year old and
had an opportunity with another guy to
do some contract work for General
Electric in robotics offline programming
robots artificial vision stuff like that
this is back in the mid 80s and so we
started a company and that one thing led
to next we had I wrote some software on
the IBM PC 1986 to do robot simulation
on a PC when we couldn't find any 3d
software that had a floating-point
database you know on a PC when at that
time you had to get a non IBM and IBM
compatible computer to get 640k of
memory IBM only shipped up to 512 K of
memory and saying we were doing
simulations those you know multiple
robots and things all on you know this
little computer it was pretty cool so
when the robotics thing ran out we took
our software to SIGGRAPH I remember Joel
or coming around asking did we have
bullying's yet I said no I'm working on
it and he said oh I think you'll find
that hard to do but we had it by the end
of the year and eventually sold off that
software got contracts in Asia to
develop software on UNIX it was meant to
be a replacement for CATIA and other
systems that were really expensive this
is late 1980s
we did it so we we decided to do it
something that we didn't see at that
time which was not only hide and
surfacing but being able to create
cellars with classy services in a
parametric history style environment
with integrated can so this all began in
the late 1980s preceded in the early
1990s we had a few large companies
interested in buying us out
unfortunately in our development it was
joint development with an Asian company
where we had 50/50 ownership in the
source code and they wouldn't cut loose
with their 50% so then SolidWorks came
along Solid Edge came along we swear
lost our window and having done
parametric modeling you know long before
those guys released it and when in a lot
of years of software development saw it
off majority ownership in the company at
one point in kind of survival mode and
just you know ended our way through this
industry always this sort of that I
think a background not as well known
Clair you know I feel like we had done
some really nice things and
nine years ago required by ZW soft a
Chinese company that I was looking into
do cab by Chinese for Chinese into home
di P so we had 3d we have around Colonel
this equivalent to parasol and aces for
c3 stealthily
and they've done really well with the
software a lot of the you know the sales
are being driven out of mainland China
with large companies there but they have
you know or marketing and a lot of what
we consider the emerging nations and
have a really good growth rate and so
I've gotten into you know so I've been
in this industry almost 35 years now now
I'm getting to finally see kind of
flowering or fruits of the labors which
is really cool for me yeah and seeing
people you know making hay with the
software and so what seemed like a long
and arduous truck but yeah the reason I
started was to be self-employed
ironically you know I've had majority
shareholders like Samsung corporations
and large Japanese Lloris Japanese
company machine to a manufacturer but
kind of felt like self-employment I was
always in charge of you know my office
and my people and is still that way
so you know I guess to embarrass myself
on the camera here as my wife and family
will in Firenze will the test one of my
first loves of my life as as any kind of
board sport but first surfing and
secondarily snowboarding I'm in Florida
so we don't get to do that much except
for only vacation so self-employment for
me that flexibility to surf in
flexibility to see against our forecast
for Central America and go down there
and get it well again it was good and
they come back and work and I'm if there
is a driver for me I don't know I didn't
really take CAD CAM I sort of fell into
it I enjoy it is I think it's really
cool yeah I mean there's a lot of
exciting things still to be done in the
space and I still have a lot of ideas
for it but yeah in the beginning I just
kind of wanted to be a beach bum and
have a way to fund that lifestyle if
there's there's so many components to
that of the 35 years that you just
unpacked a lot of people are feeling
like their work in their PhD pursuit is
not translating to industry it's only
being read by a couple people etc and
there's a strong desire to for people to
want to see their work be influenced
more people so that is and also just the
whole process of just poor incentives
around science around getting PhDs and
then be able to fill really powerful
roles as entrepreneurs or in industry
it's not really that clear or
professorship is exactly what those
those paths are like and then like you
were indicating there's a certain as
you're an entrepreneur there's a certain
timing is such an important thing and
and of course distribution of products
at the right people and getting in the
eyeballs getting the attention the right
people and so when these sort of waves
come and to be able to ride the wave and
make really cool advancements like you
did and then see that okay well is it
being are we is there being a bite or we
eating a bite here from from someone too
as interested in in acquiring us okay
maybe we didn't there but can you
persevere can you go through the
adversity in order to get to the next
wave up where you can actually get that
acquisition or get the next big deal
that you need to really ramp yourself up
and through that's a very important
thing is that that perseverance and it's
also funny that of course that you with
your mentality are you love board sports
surfing snowboarding so tell us more
about that that that personality you
know the Demark behind the the work mark
the one that you were just teaching us
about a bit on the on the sports the
connecting to earth the philosophy side
of things the way you raise your child
so I have two children a boy and a girl
I have two and I have three
grandchildren now and I have to say my
family is the highlight the best thing I
have going in life what means the most
to me and
but yeah the mark behind the mark the
philosophy I guess I grew up in a fairly
strong religious tradition within my
family and I think as I got older like
everyone you try to dig a little deeper
really examine your beliefs and what you
believe most fundamentally so that got
me in the you know reading and pondering
a lot of you know a lot of writings from
Eastern religions and you know there's
so many books out there that have been
written the your after you book and I
mean there's just all kinds of
incredible things that have been written
but they all seem to in their essence
point back to some you know some basic
you know what we might call truths and
at some point I got into more formal
meditation practices and things like
interesting that that's where we're on a
somewhere vibe I'd be interested which
meditation practices well you know
there's a lot yeah and I think you can I
mean I think formal meditation is really
just trying to point us towards you know
a certain way of living yeah with
greater awareness yes and and then it
becomes you know form of maybe walking
meditation yeah I feel like so I've
tried a few different formal meditation
practices probably the one I use most is
a sitting meditation you know with
beginning with the mantra but
and with just you know just elevating
yourself into that space and yes
because I feel like that's very warm the
goal would be that you know my entire
life would be a in every action would be
a meditative expression of that state
it's not yeah and I don't know that
we'll be in this lifetime but but there
are things that I try to do each day to
help me cultivate awareness it's always
interesting to see how quickly you can
fall out of that absolutely and kind of
become unconscious for long periods of
times right while you're fully
functioning within society but and you
can tell a big difference between when
you in the past have not practiced
meditation and how quickly potentially
you could get triggered or upset by
things and or not even be in control
like you said in a very unconscious way
but then when you do practice meditation
you can really quickly end up seeing the
benefits stacked over time where where
you won't feel more in control that you
feel more conscious you feel more heart
center you feel more aware you feel more
interconnected
and and then you're not catching
yourself reacting potentially negatively
carrying a positive weight or you're
able to see it coming you can see that
I've started to rise within you and
you're able to identify it maybe kind of
back away that's right kind of get
behind it a little bit that's right so I
would have to say I mean I am typically
fairly private about this which is why
this is an unusual situation for me he
got me that work but but it's kind of I
see that as sort of my family is first
but for me to be a good father and a
husband and good grandfather what I do
with myself internally to me is the most
important thing I can do for my family
and for society to society yeah and I
feel like it would manifest through
everything that I do and so getting the
prime directive is to cultivate that
connection with what you know some
people call divine nature with God with
the Spirit of God with consciousness
pure intelligence lighter truth or
whatever you want to call it there all
different ways of expressing this thing
that that once we experience it it
becomes you know it becomes reality the
essence of reality and we were having a
conversation at the table about
empirical versus you know mystical
taught beliefs but I feel like that
you know there's a lot of people out
there and you see it in their behavior
and their writings that have experienced
a truth that's not able to be easily
described with words but then that
becomes very meaningful and something
that is as real as you know what we
would normally talk about as a reality
yeah and so for me trying to tap into
that and connect to that you know more
than one second a day or a few minutes a
week that's really what is sort of what
I've is my goal in this life I'm in and
to try to let bleed out into what I do
when you find that the best way that you
can be a great member to your family and
your community and society is by being
your best self and then the techniques
and practices of becoming that best self
including this meditation practice like
you said that a couple seconds or a
couple minutes a week that you can
connect to what feels like all that is
or that is some sort of divine communion
that is some potentially past the 3d
reality that is again mystical versus
the empiricist which we were having a
very interesting discussion about the
scientists have to give a little bit of
breathing space for some of the
mysticism in order for us to really poke
it with the scientific probe and
understand it and some of the really
far-out mysticism can do a better job at
making sure we come back to science and
test and reproduce and stuff that as you
explain that it also resonates in me
really deeply what
see how you became who you are because
of those principles that you've lived
your life with and that has that makes
all the difference in the lifetime when
you carry that weight with you with your
family or community in society
so alright on a on another philosophical
level what have you felt then with that
couple seconds that couple minutes that
you communal it'll better than that but
yeah sometimes it's better than that
absolutely yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
think the goal is to try to incorporate
that into everyday living so that your
life becomes your practice I can
meditate in practice or whatever you
want to call it but yeah yeah conscious
living yeah yeah
so that I interrupted you what was the
question yeah that well that that is
that is your leading right into what
what what I did ask you're giving the
answer to right now I've I'm very much
agree and I'm and I'm I'm trying to in
many ways with what we're doing with the
show were really trying to help not only
take the edge of specific fields one of
them being meditation mysticism
spirituality and bringing that edge down
to the base camp where every child is
born how can they follow a superhighway
out to the spirituality or meditation
edge just like they can follow a
superhighway out to the robotics or the
biotech well that is right I've thought
a lot I thought what if I'd if I had I
don't like to say I know a lot but the
little that I feel like I know which you
know another year to goes by and you
realized there's a you know there's an
infinite depth yes to knowing but what
if I had known that as a young parent
and could there have been a way that I
could teach that to my children and what
advantage would that be to them but a
really rewarding thing for me is to see
my daughter's my daughter and
daughter-in-law exploring some of those
things that on their own that they
because people you can you you kind of
have you can't really be forced into
being interested
and things like you know meditation or
understanding yourself better and people
just seem to take their path to get
there and it often doesn't seem like
it's going to be rushed but at the same
time but but I feel like they're now
incorporating some of that you know
mindfulness principles into raising
their children that's right and there
are books out there that teach that to
parents yeah and I see that and I even
hold schools that teach that yeah yeah
yeah and it's great yes really
you know as a grandparent it's really
gratifying to see that my grandchildren
or spiritually actualized I feel great
having that that advantage I mean I I
mean I still practice you know involved
in formal religion you know a tradition
of my father so to speak you know my
family is my grandchildren are and I
feel like it's a great thing those
external practices or anchoring I think
they help keep people in an ethical
moral path until maybe they discover
what lies beneath that and I have hope
for that to continue and my family is a
family tradition
I don't have any angst over anyone that
we're departing that track but at the
end of the day you you really want to
see your you know the evolution of
family and society towards you know that
deeper
maybe understanding you know I don't
want to sound like I've got all the
answers but I feel like never does I
mean I definitely believe that that
question ourselves are our deep
ourselves is what yeah helps stabilize
our external lives and stabilize our
society and yeah you know can elevate us
to that even at a higher world that we
aspire to yeah there's there's
simultaneously is a quest that we're
running within ourselves to find out who
we are and to be our best selves and
then we're simultaneously running a
quest for society and civilization to be
the best they can be and there seem to
be at times lots of seeds the minds that
are born into the world that lacked the
basic nutrients that the seed needs in
order to creatively flourish sometimes
it's a lack of basic nutrition sometimes
it's all lack of love and compassion
from parents that are not present with
the child there's all different types of
traumas that can impact that seed and
we've had too many generations at times
of seeds experiencing trauma and that's
in many ways at times why we see such
malevolence occur sometimes on on the
planet why we have sometimes such
ignorance because we had these oops
moments with the development of the
seeds and so what are your thoughts
about that mentality of this
flourishing in the world and getting the
basic nutrients it needs in order to go
on that quest for the self-actualization
and the societal actualization
so
I don't you know I could think of some
sort of pad response to some that I feel
like you know for starters in our world
I mean I agree with what you're saying
100% but I feel like you know we all
start out when we're young were born
innocent and then we sort of have the
fall from grace as we begin we begin to
you know be attracted by the sensory
delights of the world and that begins to
consume our attention we develop a sense
of story about ourselves our ego and I
think that's a national thing that
happens in this necessary in order for
us to
to be individuals and have the
experience of individual and interacting
with individual even though I would
contend that we're all one at the
foundation of things and so I think in
solving world issues with children I
don't think you can necessarily take
people directly to things that a lot of
people would consider more esoteric even
though they feel natural to us so I
think the beginning does just
strengthening families having societies
and cultures and governments respect the
family in trying to generate a societal
support and you can look at it negative
as you want but as a societal
expectation of people that have children
being good parents you know fulfilling
parental responsibilities towards those
children even if it means sacrificing
their own kind of egoic wants and needs
I think there needs to be almost like a
societal peer pressure on people to just
stuff up you know they have children
then set aside your ego your ego or
other things that you think you'd rather
be doing and you know teach your your
children and I think if yeah even doing
that is an act of consciousness or self
discipline one guy said that
spirituality is consciousness of victory
over self
to be a disciplined parent you need you
have to consciously choose to make
sacrifices and if your children are
crying and this making a young mother
crazy they have to transcend that
frustration and anger that arises they
request an act of transcendence to get
into that place and in fact I feel like
parenting is probably one of the
ultimate you know battle feels or
schoolyards or whatever you want to call
it to find your higher self because you
have to transcend more opposition to you
have opposition that has to be
transcended in order to do your job but
I think the starting point is teaching
children morality and ethics that gives
them a foundation I feel like the roots
of a tree that hold it in place yes when
they have that foundation and basic
morality and ethics then they can raise
their branches and the you know the what
people called mystical realms I don't
look at it exactly that way but they are
then anchored in a place where they're
more likely to discover some of those
ideas of consciousness and awareness and
and I discover more that their true
spiritual nature or their more you know
eternal nature
but I think that in the beginning maybe
it just starts out like you know
teaching your children to be nice to
each other yeah kind of thing yeah so
let's let's do a couple things off of
that first thing was that there's a
there it's true that one of the ways we
can level up the most in life is by
having the child because we quickly
understand how to be more selfless we
quickly understand how to transcend our
own ego and how to really focus on like
you said there are these interesting
forces that the child might be
relentlessly crying or trying to get
what it wants when it's out and about
and that is your intentions in a sense
it's your role to to stay calm and to
stay calm and to stay president to
engage with the child at their creative
potential at their at their at their at
their exact cognitive capabilities and
and that's a whole challenge as you as a
twenty-five thirty-five forty-five year
old how do you engage with three six
nine twelve year old at their cognitive
capabilities to help them understand the
world that they're in this is a massive
undertaking and in order to do it well
one has to like you said go through
these these transcendent experiences
with with parenting and and I completely
agree the only reason why humans got
swear we did it one of them only reasons
because we ended up procreating the
whole lineage of people that ended up
bringing you into the world and me and
all the people watching right now the
other thing that you mentioned was this
foundation you know if the seed that is
born into the world gets morality and
ethics really strongly understood and
these roots come in like you said it
gives them the
City to be able to reach up towards
their self-actualization what would you
say are those fundamental roots of
morality and ethics well I don't know I
mean you could sum it all up and as
you're repeating back to me what I said
I thought well really what children need
is love and true love and true love will
correct children when they you know need
correction but it does it in it in a
kind of useful way you know not a
violent sort of way not an angry way and
so I guess in a children but up in a
loving environment I think they're more
likely to learn patterns of love from
the example that their parents and
grandparents and family said so you know
when you think about ethics and morality
you can think about Ten Commandments or
a lot of you know every religion has
their basic you know things about you
know not stealing and you know being
honest you know you know right speech
right conduct which usually means some
form of not violating the agency of
other people I'm not harming other
people or harming life intentionally so
those are some of the basics I guess
that come to mind but again I just
you know at all you can bowls down to
being loving and kind creating that
environment so that's what your children
learn but absorption or above
observation or by just seeping into the
essence of who they all right I did
think those I made the comment about
parenting there's a lot of people that
don't have the opportunity to have
children oh don't choose that path and I
wouldn't want that comment to be at all
you know offensive to them that's why we
some one of the most meaningful yeah but
yeah and I think if people in my life
that were not my biological parents but
that parented me and I and in as I
expanded on that thought or would expand
on it I feel like in business we have so
many roles in life on the business
manager can nurture his employees you
can be a manager that tries to get
perform that's but fear and that degree
can produce but I feel like it's a
higher road elicit perform this through
you know loving compassionate behavior
just by seán genuine respect and
kindness to your employees and I feel
like they'll perform and even a higher
level under that sort of atmosphere the
one that fear
as a shout-out to the current company
that I worked with in China I feel like
they're top management in particular
their CEO just thinking about these kind
of things too and it reflects in the way
that he behaves and what his values are
yeah and how he manages the company and
so it's been a real pleasure for me to
to work with someone that you know
there's thinking that way in trying to
translate that into action yeah
especially through the business world
and through industry that that type of
those moralities and ethics that could
be baked into the roots being being
brought forth into business and into
culture into society that has a
tremendous butterfly effect on to other
other people as well like you said are
we leading with love and compassion are
we leading with fear so yeah I also
agree with what you were talking about
regarding the the roots that are that
are baked in the morals and ethics that
are baked in these are in many ways
these are these sort of when we think
about things ask code it really helps us
understand that what would be the first
lines of code that you would want every
child to be born with and every parent
to adapt today every human to adapt
today
well what if nobody would kill each
other well then there would be no
malevolence then we may not need any war
then we could save trillions of dollars
every single year and invest that into
education there's a lot of potential
that can be explored by these thinking
about things as code as morals and
ethics and what we would like to embed
into the next generations that are
birthed into our world you have children
and grandchildren you hope you get to
see this firsthand as you know you
passing along the knowledge that
collective knowledge and they get to
build up with that into new knowledge
bases and it's it's a very beautiful
thing
alright mark let's ask you about what we
were talking about at the table I want
to you know bring up now in in many ways
there is a there's almost a culture of
small talk that is in in many ways just
plaguing our world that were we're lost
in mundane conversation we're scared or
fearful to to sit down and have deeper
conversations or we might make a mistake
and then we'll feel judged or whatever
it may be but this is like when you go
and shoot your first basketball you
don't make it right away it takes a long
time to become a good player at whatever
you do so therefore similarly with
asking good questions it's it's about
working this muscle and getting really
good asking questions and being fearless
about it and then over time realizing
that what you catalyze when you ask a
good question is not only are you
learning from what the person responds
to you're getting them to think in an
interesting way about a question they
may not have thought about before then
they may go talk to someone else about
that question and then people are
thinking bigger about humanity about
society about themselves about our
purpose so I want you to you know speak
to us about the importance of shattering
through that so surface-level
conversations to the bigger question I
think you've addressed it pretty well
yeah I don't know that I have much to
add to that I do agree that sometimes
when
I mean I enjoy talking about some of the
things we've talked about because
they're meaningful to me but I find that
I generally hold back because of kind of
the blank or slightly quizzing not more
than quizzical looks that you get and it
or the discomfort you know that it seems
to cost so it's nice to run into someone
like you that enjoys talking about this
as much as I do
yeah we do get along quite well on that
front I want to I want to see what you
think about this well when potentially
there is a little bit of discomfort that
one the other person may experience when
when you prompt them with with the
thought provoking question at times it
almost feels like that is then a is it
actually okay to ask something that may
discomfort someone well so I think the
way you pulled it off at the table was
good I mean so I have a couple thoughts
that come to mind and hopefully they'll
they won't they'll make sense
somebody somebody you know philosopher
writer that was - my famous like yes
said paraphrase something in fact that
you know he was defining my right
speaking or truth and he says went in
speaking and he says when you speak to
speak truly is not just to speak
actually because gossip is factual and
you know inherently since it's not
necessarily the right speaking but that
is you know factual but also useful and
kind so sometimes I feel like in
conversations with people if it's making
them uncomfortable maybe I'm not being
kind towards them to try to draw them
into something that that I enjoy but
it's causing discomfort for them yeah
but on the other hand I and there's an
idea don't throw your pearl in front of
swine's sometimes things that you hold
near and dear if you put it out there
and you get a real you know rough
reaction to it or it's sort of just it
it it it there's a lowering of energy is
sort of or they just they don't have a
sense of reverence and respect and what
you consider totally it can just sort of
be a downer experience and maybe just
seems counterproductive but on the other
hand I as I say that I feel like we
can't back down there's some
responsibility that we have to speak
where there's something this Zen masters
that says we must speak you know even
though words never adequately describe
truth that we mustn't that we have to
try so we must speak but I feel like you
know what you did at the table you were
in a way it was a terrible act to the
rest of the table because things had
gotten quiet you know so you helped us
have some conversation help liven things
up so it wasn't a selfish thing you were
doing and even though maybe created a
little discomfort I think if you know if
you saw that someone's really being put
off but it's not like you're you know
like you're gonna just drive it home
it's so that emotional intelligence
component to it is that you can sense
the difference between someone that
becomes very discomfort and then when
you feel that about them then you push
but then you are you lay off and but
then when someone like you who is like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna reply like this
I don't like this conversation and then
well
the thing is I've found that sometimes
whenever I'll drop hints about things
I'm interested in and you can you know
if I sense that someone was responsive
sometimes I find like you that there are
people out there that you know wanna
discuss those type of issues yes and
soon to feel uplifted by the opportunity
and and and then it becomes a two-way
sort of you know give and good
experience and then there will look for
others at the table that became very
interested and engaged and they also
started giving their their thoughts
about it and that was that was also very
cool too to have catalyzed that and yeah
generated some community and yes yes
it's a lavender and some interesting
states of awareness these are the things
that can happen from these from these
big bigger questions and and being
willing to step into that into that
curiosity and and and big questions are
great and another thought for you
question is through this practice that
you've had through life through raising
family as well as through your
meditation what has been your sort of
this this as you as you aim to to to
commune in to transcend what what what
is this that that you are engaged with
what do you what do you what is what has
passed that that through the 3d reality
well some want to get myself in trouble
I think it's like you know the feeling
the different parts of the elephant oh
you know you can't describe one thing
and someone feels like you kind of
missed the boat because they saw another
aspect of that reality so but I you know
I feel like we described in various ways
you know God consciousness light and
truth I feel like there's an essence
from which everything arises I might
tend to think of it as like truth
intelligence the Spirit of God but I
believe you know there's religions that
seem to get a little unsettled towards
the idea of you know God in a form any
kind of form because they feel like he's
too big to be able to manifest in form
and there's others that feel like that's
the main way they see him as a
benevolent being person is you know like
us human and I believe in all of the
above I feel like you know there's
levels of creation outside of this world
that were engaged with and I feel like
there are people that we call prophets
and teachers that are able to see
outside the world I feel like we reach a
would have direct experience of that if
we look for and and so I think they're
you know there's beings that are
probably higher than us in the sense of
their attainment of benevolence and love
that that you know or participate in the
drama of this particular world in life
and and some people worship those you
know celestial beings and some people
worship
essence from which they arose that pure
light and truth which is their very
essence and I don't really have a beef
with any of it I think it's just
different viewpoints and Orsi and slices
of the what's out there but i but i
bleed the fundamental essence of
everything is pure intelligence or
consciousness yeah yeah yeah what we
call energy is patterns of like
consciousness vibrating in different
patterns and formations and it's kind of
interesting a lot of the quantum physics
you know there's some of the physicists
that aren't afraid of you know going
against the tradition you know the the
idea of science is pure and Pyrrhic
ilysm even though that's sort of a
subjective type term to but you know
there's the and their experimentation
realized that the very act of design and
experience we tend to see what we set
out to measure we can design the
apparatus we conceive of what we're
trying to measure see some new particle
we designed the apparatus to measure it
that very act of creation generally
allows them to see so it's the idea of
subject an object or one and those are
mystile mystical concepts but a lot of
them are realizing that as they try to
describe the results of experiments or
where you know the particle being split
through the two slits you know that they
can change something after the
quote-unquote particle or wavelet is
passed through the slits and it'll jump
to the other slit it'll hit via as if it
came through the other slip so slit so
there's you know there same time kind of
dissolve and they can hardly speak about
what they're seeing without doing in
terms that we would ordinarily think of
as mystical terms
as they're trying to you know get down
to the basis of reality so but I but I
feel like you know if I sit here and say
that energy or is or you know are
patterns or vibrations of consciousness
that's just one way of probably trying
to crudely describe something that is
only known but not really it exists
outside of the duality or creation so to
try to cast it into words as yeah yeah
yeah you know difficult to ask question
so whatever ask you know I fear this
interview like this is whatever words I
say could be picked apart our dissected
or refuted by another person and I
wouldn't really argue with him over it
is again it's just ways of trying to
describe things but what I if I was
making a pitch to anyone that didn't had
a real strong opposition of the kind of
things that we discussed it sound like
quote-unquote mysticism which I'll just
say what's reality let's just say all go
experience it for yourself craft better
that's do the right things and then it
becomes your personal experience and you
don't really have to you don't need me
to try to convince you of it yep you
know I never will it has to be it has to
be experience has to be experiential
wisdom yep yep there's so many things
that you said in that last segment maybe
the the most important thing for me is
that when one does tap into this
this overwhelming feeling of love
abundance truth bliss god consciousness
all that is whatever one wants to label
it as that that feeling transcends every
else and that that is that is a real
that is some we talk about that on the
show so much with so many different
leaders and guess even really scientific
people you speak in this way as well and
that's really beautiful when you marry
those two things together yeah because
then you're you're really starting to
dig at what is the truth with the
scientific method plus you're able to
when you are also scientifically
literate you can talk to other people
that are in science and help them become
more interested in poking at what is
missed this considered mystical as well
so I agree
those three words they were life or
light truth and intellect or
intelligence
yeah intelligence and that those arised
here post Big Bang and we now see that
in everything and that is so gorgeous
and we talked about the the oneness
versus the dualism as well and that is
also very very interesting as a topic
any other thoughts on the way out I
wanna also respect you know your time
and everything and if you have other
thoughts that that you want to share now
or any closing remarks we can say those
and then we can know yeah just don't
judge me guys by this interview but um
no I appreciate the opportunity and it's
been good to you know interact with you
on this stuff
thanks Bart thank you so much for coming
on the show and talking to us a really
appreciate it
and don't don't don't worry at all the
interesting thing is is that we have
this grew so grateful for people that
actually watched the show and the the
whole notion of
of whatever it is that anonymity and
cyberbullying on the Internet all these
types of things the the channel and the
audience are very very very good at
being respectful and engaging and
thought-provoking with with the content
and and more people stepping up and
speaking about how they feel on camera
and passing that along to younger people
like what you're doing is extremely
important so we actually treat you like
a role model for doing so inspiring
other people to step up and do that same
thing so thank you all right thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know also do check out the links to
Kofi's below check out the links the
simulation below support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
support us our links are below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon